the Joe Rogan experience and one of the
things that's really good about church
is the community yes I mean this to me
connects to the thing that we opened by
talking about which is polarization and
tribal you know the tribal politics were
living in I think you've had Jonathan
hight on the show and his book the
righteous mind is brilliant about this
that we were evolved to be religious
creatures in a certain way and what
happens when we lose religion that
impulse goes somewhere yeah I think that
impulse has gone into you know politics
in the culture or yes you know it's like
why are the stakes of that so
unbelievably high because that is sort
of the operating system that people are
organizing their life around 100 percent
right I think it's the Protestants
versus the Catholic but it's like what
what do we do right because we're not
gonna go back like to convince people
that are unconvinced that they're you
know I think fighting for the idea of
God is sort of a losing argument in the
culture so how do we retain the good
things that came from religious
structures in a post god age I think
that's a huge question well what are
what are people really wary of one of
the things that wary of is the recluse
right we're wary
we're aware of the Unabomber wearing
that that guy who lives in the woods and
and doesn't the the isolationist who
doesn't need anybody else there by
themselves like well that person doesn't
follow by the rules of our community
well what are we comfortable about we're
comfortable about friendly neighbors
we're comfortable okay you need help you
know you need me to help dig you out of
the snow do you need this do you need
that like that's what we love right
because then and we love people that
share our values right we like to live
in a community of shared values because
then you like you're all we're all
comforting each other we're all saying
we're all in this together we're gonna
have hardships we're gonna have good
times but the the will have more good
times we'll get through the hardships if
we operate together with similar values
yeah but we're kind of we're not living
in the age of the Unabomber but we're
certainly living in an age where people
are completely isolated
you know everyone on the campaign trail
is talking about the diseases of despair
and how the lifespan in this country has
gone down for the
three life expectancy has gone down in
the past three years because of Trump
because you're out of work because
because factories are closing because
we're going through whatever andrian
calls at the fourth Industrial
Revolution because of globalization
because like we're living through an
unbelievably transfer what I think will
be remembered is an unbelievably
transformative time and Trump is only
one data point yes like he's a symptom
and he's a catalyst but he's not the
whole picture and to see him as the
whole picture I think is just like
completely missing the moment that we're
in well put very well put yeah I think I
really think you you just nailed it I
really think that's a lot of what's
going on here and I think I mean what
you said but people enjoying when people
can speak their mind when people see
someone like Ricky Gervais get up at the
Golden Globes and say yes yes or like
chappelle's like Chappelle's you're like
that to me Wilbur's yeah but the
Chappelle one was so good because if you
looked at Rotten Tomatoes right the
critics rating of it was something like
twenty percent favorable no it was zero
first it was zero yeah and then they'll
open it up to the public what the only
99 percent you know and it's like we
just keep living that out again and
again and again and I just wonder like
how that resolves itself or maybe it
doesn't it does it resolves itself to a
conversation like this yeah
that's really what it is but the people
or when you hammer I come to meet the
common man young the common man and
basically I mean when we talk and people
listen to reasonable discussion then
they feel more emboldened to have
reasonable discussion of their own maybe
perhaps in private maybe I have to
[ __ ] put tinfoil over the windows and
bolt the door shut and make sure that
they can talk that's insane
yeah it is like we're living in the
freest society in human history and
people are acting like the Stasi is
looking over their shoulder yes because
it is media social media folks
no for real look if I wasn't promoting
comedy shows and podcasts and I'd like I
don't think I'd be on it
I would I would definitely be off of it
I mean I'm on it now but I'm on it like
a posted and leaveit thing I don't pay
attention the luxury of that yes you
know no no I don't know I think about
like what would it look like if all the
journalists at the Washington Post the
New York Times and Wall Street Journal
were banned from being on Twitter
nope for real because like what happens
right is like it's this circular thing
where we all know the land mines right
like the things we don't want to touch
like the hills we don't want to die on
and it's what's scary about the stasi
like atmosphere of it is like my job is
to write opinion columns and commission
other people to do that and yet I feel
the self censoring even before I've
written right where I'm like wait I
don't want to die on that hill I don't
want to die on that is that really the
battle I want to take on I should
probably just stick to this topic
instead of that topic because I know if
I do that topic like I know it awaits me
yes like why am i why would I willingly
go to the guillotine yes you know it's
like and people pretend like the
reputational smears have no cost like
they're insane well that's what's weird
about your position because you're an
opinion writer right I mean that's what
you do correct and you're not allowed to
give your honest opinion in a lot of
people's eyes they want you to be
compliant with what culture and I think
one of the reasons that I get in a lot
of trouble or I'm provocative or
whatever the words that go before my
name are whenever I mentioned now
controversial is because I you know I
think more than other people I refuse to
follow the rule because what's the point
like we're all gonna be in the crown yes
like I'm not gonna waste my life
following some fake rule determined by
random people on the internet no and
like this desire for you to comply I
mean this is part of the game that's
going on when people don't have control
of their own lives they love to control
other people's lives and one of the
things that happens when you have an
opinion that does not follow the you
know whatever the path has been clearly
grooved for us to when you you're
supposed to have very specific ideas
about
is very clearly defined subjects when
you deviate from those and people start
attacking you their what they're trying
to do in many there's a lot of what
they're trying to do this it's nuanced
but one of the things are trying to do
is they're trying to get you to listen
to them so that they have some power
they feel powerless in the world and if
they can push your button if they can
break your glass then they have some
power but they're also trying to issue a
warning right they're issuing a warning
to the people in their group saying if
you deviate we're gonna do to you what
we're doing to her right now yes and
it's gonna be relentless and you know
and it's just like what's sad about it
it's like the number of young people I
know who are so talented and you know or
heterodox are just independent minded
people like liberals they choose not to
become public people like right they
decide not to go into journalism not to
do comedy not to do any number of things
because like why would you choose to you
know be in that arena if this is what it
means
[Applause]